voici ce qui va changer en france à
partir du 1er juillet 2022 le plafond
des tickets restaurant va baisser de 38
à 10,9 euros et ils ne pourront plus
être utilisée ni les week-ends ni les
jours fériés le salaire des
fonctionnaires va augmenter de 3,5 pour
cent l'horloge parlante joignable par
téléphone au 36 99 à disparaître il ne
sera plus possible d'installer des
chaudières au fioul ou au charbon les
démarches pour changer de nom de famille
seront simplifiées il sera désormais
possible de prendre le nom de sa mère de
son père où les deux par simple
déclaration à l'état civil les
fabricants de casques de moto vont
devoir s'adapter à une nouvelle norme et
produire des casques plus sécurisé trois
substances parfumantes la tra nole le
cloître à nole et leptine carbonate de
métier ils seront interdites dans les
jeux ou jouets pour enfants enfin à
partir du 6 juillet tous les nouveaux
modèles de véhicules devront être
équipés d'une boîte noire